- This is actually interesting
because when this next artist
when I heard her record, Olivia Rodrigo
I literally told all look
and I literally said
she, y'all are very different artists but,
I listened to her album
from beginning to end
and I was like, I'm 40
and I'm really into this.
And I was like, and it's so good.
And I feel like it's
like a different version
of like you, like, I feel
like y'all are very similar.
I feel like you're different but,
- I thought man, she had to have been
- Ya, similar fabric
- like influenced by you a bit because,
I feel like she was that
artist that I feel like
for her generation was like,
my generation's like Alanis.
And so, so is it true that you gave her,
I heard some kind of survival
like road, survival kit.
(Alanis laughing)
- She, she mentioned she
was going on the road
and hadn't done that a lot
and I just thought, oh, okay.
- Your voice is gonna die.
- Well, yeah and then also there's
there's sort of,
archetypaly constitutionally
you're either kind of a
road dog or you're not.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- And I think those of
us who are road dogs
we have little tricks up our sleeve
of what to bring to
survive for self care even.
So for me, it's about, you
know, bringing the equivalent
of my blankie everywhere I go, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- It's, it's as simple as a pillow
- [Kelly] Your comforts
- Yeah, and so I think I
mentioned in our conversation
Olivia and my conversation
that I would send her
a care package. And I
really should get on that.
(Kelly laughs)
Thanks for reminding me
Kelly but I will and I can.